yo what's up i'm hip dustin yeah yeah
yeah i'm dustin when he reaches the 90's
[Laughter]
bright hip-hop and career eddie
guys stranger things episode two today
get ready to enjoy this reaction i'm
assuming and hoping if uh you're
interested become a super sexy reject
today where you'll catch the full length
watch alongs for stranger things over
there and we cover a whole bunch of
shows where some of them are reaction
highlights exclusives for patreon and if
you can't do that leave a like and it's
not too hard to ask is it also subscribe
and click that notification bell to
notify when our next stranger things
reaction is up here on the channel and
then boys at prepper wouldn't be able to
do the schedule we got currently if it
wasn't for each and every one of you
there hire them
aft after after this minute
away from our work yeah yeah the love of
god
[Music]
[Music]
oh
he simply ran away
[Laughter]
very plausible escape
[Music]
i think all of us are predicting some
crazy explanation of like explosion
sentiment to something that transports
maybe russia got de-materialized
turned into electrical current and he
was transported and spat back out he
just ran away
he just jumped to the next level down
[Music]
choice i'm in russia
find me in russia i'm a prisoner
[Laughter]
looks like that munson boy's up to no
good again
we heard there's a dutchess dragons game
going on over here put down the dice
holy mother of god no you guys got to
move out of hawkins
everybody needs to move out of
hawkins i can't be out here get back
inside
back inside
or
are you a witness at all to my
videos
suspicious yesterday perhaps people
returning to the trailer
we're out of hawkins it's a gift i uh i
hand picked those for you and hawkins
i know you like yellow but now i'm kind
of realizing that it's too much yellow i
know you also like purple so i got some
purple as well so i kind of did like a
70 30 split kind of thing perfect
complementary colors it's good all that
writing she doesn't just tell for me
are your friends going to meet us there
friends what what friends you know stacy
and angela
angela you'll meet them i promise just
not today i want today
to be about me and me and definitely not
about will at all i crime she crumpled
this
painting
the body of a hawkins high student was
discovered early this morning police
have not yet released the victim's name
although we are told they're currently
in the process of notifying the family
the first season was like i'm kidnapping
and this one's a murderer
yeah
small town murder what's this i thought
we were watching thundercats hugging
student got murdered
oh [ __ ] oh
they say who it is no not yet
hey maybe chrissy didn't stand you up
after all hey don't say that
this town's turned upside down
yeah he's like a super nice guy but then
he's murdering women on the weekends
he's saying eddie is like ted bundy it's
more like richard ramirez night stucco
after i saw eddie and chrissy go in the
trailer something else happened
okay all right they really are playing
with time a lot yes i love it
maybe he was
scared because you know he just killed
someone or amy but because something
else
killed her
but that's impossible
not here i don't know there's only one
person who knows what actually happened
eddie oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] rusty where are you going to see
your friend you heard the news it's not
safe good point we'll be extra careful
thanks mama love you bye
[Laughter]
this looks and reads like a ransom note
and a bad one at that there's no proof
of life here yes there is it's signed
enzo so so
there's only two people who knew about
our date at enzos and that's me and hop
yes
he's sending me a message
you saw him die joyce
i didn't see a body always room for a
sequel he evaporated or he survived okay
okay
what's he doing in russia he was
captured that's what ben he probably met
some new friends and by friends i mean
the kgb
no matter how strong you think jim is
they will get his whole life story and
yes that might very well include a
planned date at enzo's with you his
co-conspirator
[Laughter]
you just made all that up
it's a theory
this could be real hopper could be alive
i suppose there's only one way to find
out
but go to russia
we're gonna call that number
and we're going to find out who the hell
sent you that letter but we're doing it
my way yeah buddy
who you work with
no one
oh
this woman
who is she
don't you tell me
she's wearing a russian uniform
oh
some good noise dampening gloves
poor hopper man goes through all that
work to help save the day
she's capturing the torture gets
tortured first thanks i just
i don't think mike's gonna like that
you're lying to him and he doesn't
deserve that when he finds out he's to
be mad
okay
god damn it l break my heart
[Music]
come on will find love here at the
roller rink
[Music]
who's that twig with it
i don't know
but it seems like the snitch has a
boyfriend
i told you spring break is gonna be fun
chrissy doesn't mess with that crap
maybe someone talked her into it no she
she's straight as an arrow what about
eddie munson what does eddie have to do
with all this
did he hurt chrissy
where are you going is everything good
what they say just gonna let him walk
out there
man
hey i hope he gets his revenge against
eddie that's right
100 on jason's side now
i need it i need it for what looking up
eddie's friend's phone numbers oh eddie
your new best friend eddie you think
he's cooler than me because he plays a
nerdy game yes
i never said that
work it out boys
a student died and the game plan is for
you to let me do the talking for you to
take notes in that little pad there and
for you to follow my lead at all times
is that understood totally and
completely
hi officer can't go through here we got
a crump c a friend she lives in there
her mom is working today and we would
really like to check in on her
we're basically her nanny uh nannies
actually i do know you you're fred
benson
you killed that kid last year what
that ugly scar in your face
[Music]
it was an accident
an accident
whoa
that way you ran all the way home
instead of calling us
i said you're all right kid you're
looking a little peaked
huh
fine i'm fine he's just um on edge
i mean we are
i'm loving the horror acceptance letter
to lenora community that's where i'm
going but you're going to emerson with
nancy no she just
doesn't know it yet because if i told
her the truth then she just she'd just
throw her dreams out the window to come
out here and be with me
no
until eventually
she hates me
and then and then before you know it
we're just like my mom and dad we're
divorced my kids hate me [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
i mean it's all good
palm tree the light that's what you
gotta do palm tree the light go go go go
got me stressed out's not even my
girlfriend
where oh where have you been hiding this
handsome thing
ugh
angela
this is mike
my boyfriend
yo angela come on friend let's skate
shall we i i wanted to finish the studio
hold on to that
come on
[Music]
mike's like brother
that was weird at all
go have
fun lying to you mike [ __ ] no listen
to me she's having problems here
problems okay
what kind of problems
they're about to see that kind of
problems
[Music]
this is so upsetting
they're all going to laugh at you
beat those women mike beat it with your
bare hands
[Music]
oh my god this is such [ __ ]
[Music]
oh a crock of [ __ ]
[Music]
oh man
she better go like full hog areas yeah
this is kgb they will still be able to
trace us eventually so keep it brief how
brief a minute max and
proof of life got it thank you
this is ansel
hello enzo this is joyce
i received your message and i would like
to make a reservation yes good good
but for reservation you need to make
deposit uh
what what kind of deposit forty thousand
dollars hmm forty thousand yuri's vision
fly two days do not call again
well that wasn't the kgb
but it wasn't a friend either so we're
both wrong
he was strong american
make him a red guardian
yeah the place looks off
oh
it's not come choco
we're back with the people who were
listening on the phone calls this
transition so throwing me off yeah cops
they say chrissy went to him to buy
drugs drugs no that's what i said crazy
would never touch this [ __ ]
it's like the ring probably sacrificed
her drain your blood for the devil i
just said you must do that
why the cops go around pursuing some
some [ __ ] leads spreading rumors
saying she's some some druggie no no she
wants to go out there she wants to do
something everything's always a
basketball speech
what did i tell you when we went into
semi-finals boys
nope does this reefer rick have a last
name
right dr zhivago it's a double vhs it's
long
hello so my boyfriend won't like totally
puke when i bring it home he's gonna
he's gonna love it
yeah
see ya yeah i'll see you later
alligator
light is a dammit shot ah i beat you you
think eddie's guilty don't you whoa i
believe in innocent until proven guilty
all that constitutional [ __ ]
we've got a very big selection in here
okay it can be super overwhelming for
these people yeah it can be
we'll lure them out with vhs with free
rentals with titles
no late fees
let's narrow it down rick alderman's
latest rentals are annie and dumbo what
are the chances our drug dealers are
family not likely all right
rick conroy 16 candles teen wolf and
romance english it's got to be all porn
[Music]
kimbrough the blue lagoon and splash
rick lipton fast times at ridgemont yup
yup yup yeah let's have it seven times
him it's probably the t 2121 holland
road that's out by lovers lake middle of
nowhere it's a perfect place to hide
i wish they did all the rick names and
he was the last
so we could just read off titles well
you want to tell us everything nancy
come on let's get out of here but he's
just the cutest little witness
stay here interrogate the dog yes you're
not gonna believe what this dogs
saw the whole thing
it's all right here
i'm just
looking for something about what
happened last night as far as i can tell
you all have it figured out already my
nephew's a freak he killed that girl i'm
not about right
let me guess
you've been speaking to the hawkins post
oh my god that guy's on agents of shield
let's try to figure it out let me tell
your side of the story
do it enoch that poor girl i found this
morning same exact thing so i'm thinking
maybe he broke out like that what's his
name white mask
kill the baby sitters ha
yeah
michael myers
he asked me victor's like that
definitely not like any other slasher
character
victor creel gonna say this this season
has like a supernatural ghost slash 80s
serial killer vibe yeah
fred
don't kill fred i like fred fred's dead
baby
oh my goodness all the mourners
insidious
[Music]
murderer
[Music]
murderer
[Applause]
this town's messed up crazy ass
bug-looking creatures now you got ghosts
and [ __ ]
the government should just come aboard
the whole place though yeah the
cinematography this season is phenomenal
it's
top-notch you translate that
i can't understand it it's too low
enhance what about all the speaker
systems you got from radio shack
she's mad at enzo
calls him a moosa moosa it's slain for
what
literally
translates to trash or garbage it's like
pig here often directed at cops cops
the restaurant you died at
joyce where you going the bank get enter
is damn money
and we are getting popper back
okay
well she was lying to you mike straight
to your face ever since you got here
and and i've been a total third wheel
all day it's been miserable
so sorry if i wasn't
i wasn't smiling
yeah whatever man he's your friend too
come on
elle has like a book of letters from you
that's because she's my girlfriend will
and us we're friends well we used to be
best friends oh then maybe you should
have reached out more i i don't know why
am i the bad guy
let's just
just find her okay
you guys are always having problems we
fought tooth and nail to rescue you she
looks upset you ruined my day
i want you to say sorry to me and i want
you to tell my boyfriend that it was
just a joke we are really friends you'll
just have to cry to your daddy instead
oh wait
you can't do that
why a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
take up kickboxing al
oh
oh she's doing what she knows how to do
holy crap did she really do that yeah
oh yeah
gear on the bottom of one of those will
jack you up
ah
you [ __ ] deserved it
yeah
yeah
but still it doesn't make you feel
better
what did you do
that's what she knows angela coming
fictional character angela hadika i mean
to be fair
i think a lot of people wanted to be in
l's shoes just then so her story is
arthur fleck
yes
eddie
i thought she was gonna smash the camera
like this each story is like telling a
different uh genre
[Laughter]
some really great suspense building
shots and sequences too
steve will get him with his orb i know
you think you're being funny henderson
but considering the fact that everyone
in this room has nearly died about a
hundred times personally i don't find it
funny oh yeah
we're on your side i swear on my mother
right guys yes yes from swear
on dustin's mother yeah dustin's dozen's
mother
what if they just killed off steve
well that would he killed someone
i want to know what happened
you won't believe me
try me
trust me
hi officer
officer what are you still doing here my
friend from the car earlier i i can't
find him what do you mean you can't find
him he was there and then he was just
gone
oh come on buddy
it's it in and she just like hung there
in the air her bones started to snap
we don't think you're crazy don't
[ __ ] me man i know how this sounds
we're not bullshitting you we believe
you
recap all of seasons one through three
frames
hidden beneath hawkins sometimes it
bleeds into ours there are some things
worse than ghosts
who
oh
[Music]
no
there was nothing you could see
or uh
or touch
oh
it's crazy what is he
i want you to join me
oh
or under a spell
the curse
effect this curse
why does he do it this way
oh
an undead creature of great
power
a dark
wizard
yeah this is awesome
awesome
awesome
man attaching
yep more dread this season i like it i
like it a lot absolutely
i feel like this is definitely shaping
up to be better than last season
but damn
man
some dark ass [ __ ]
it's some darker [ __ ] man
stop
bad trip dewey cox
hip-hop dustin's back
science raps
as did all the things that we were
saying that would probably do you know
from after the first episode were like
they really focused a lot on the new
characters i want them to focus more on
our returning characters and now this
was
mainly about our returning characters
yeah we got us to learn that hopper was
still around
and he just he just got taken
yeah he just lived and then got got
arrested blend his way out of there
and then he didn't break under
interrogation so they put him away to
even crazier prisons really thought
there would just be some kind of i don't
know how i feel about that
yes i guess it's fine i don't know if it
was just some because i think a lot of
us really thought it was going to be
some kind of crazy
yeah particle acceleration transporting
thing and then things were connected to
russia the russians came over here with
their machinery yeah you know not just i
don't know we just said we just went
away you just
you just jumped down and then we found
him
right after that oh it's actually a lot
simpler in fact if joyce hadn't left
like fourth with she might have just
found him too they had to go man
russians were coming that's true that's
true that's true it wasn't time yeah
there wasn't time so
i'm still a little conflicted about that
it's funny
it sets you up for some kind of big
explanation and then to have it be like
oh no no he just ran in the proper
direction
it doesn't fully i guess circumvent the
whole still how did he survive that
devastating explosion
of this theoretical machine
uh but it's not something that like
while while yeah i'm sitting here
thinking about it uh it doesn't loom too
heavily it's not like it destroyed my
enjoyment of everything else they were
doing you know well they said it
thoroughly explains how he uh
why hasn't been back yeah
and i like to kind of gradually even
still like at the beginning of this
episode i thought they were going to
rush him on and it's going to be like
all hopper all russia yeah but i like
that where yeah even you know we get
hints at him in the first episode now we
get a couple glimpses in this one well
figuring out enzo and then having the
stories tied together yeah the way they
deal with time in this is really
interesting the inner cutting of all
these different events i think the
cinematography is just [ __ ] so
beautiful it's so beautiful
wizard exquisite stuff
and it does feel different than the
other seasons
um
like uh
not sure thematically what it is that is
the exact theme here of this one
um
because i think the other three that are
themes are really like easier to
identify
whereas
here
we're dealing with a lot of different
things right now and it's all really
cool like i think everything is really
clicking there's not a single
for longer episodes there's not a single
dull moment to me
and i like that it feels
like a bunch of
are parts of it that you know like the
it seems like with with the dustin and
you know robin and them they they are
still keeping that original flare of the
goonies vibe you know investigating
something horror
um and and and then uh
i i think like
there were like 80s there's more 70s
with like russian stuff
yeah i mean it still carries over but
but yeah i feel like that torture horror
a psychological horror vibe yeah
and then this investigative mystery with
nancy
and that genre kind of believes
throughout of this ghost story
which i think is really cool because
they haven't done ghost story yet
at least like overtly
no and it's a very i feel like
the upside down is a
really interesting motif to go into all
these different iterations of
horror plus other genre and i feel like
ghost story is just as much at home
in just a different sense i wouldn't
have necessarily thought of it at first
but i do think especially the way
they've done this whole possession and
praying on your guilt and your grief and
and using that as this this thing that
you know has a tangible counterpart but
that only manifests on our physical
plane is gonna so go after max yeah i
know
that's the thing is the second uh the
second chrissy got lifted off her feet
in the first episode i was like oh that
trailer moment where she's above the
grave that's going to be something to do
with billy
yeah yeah she probably she's she's so
he's so going after max
and it's already begun too with that
little those little flashes maybe if
it's about overcoming your guilt yeah
yeah sure maybe that's what this
season's about and confronting it and
not hiding you know from it or not
trying to soldier on like it didn't
actually happen yeah because
the other season last season was about
moving forward
um second season was ptsd and this one
is probably a lot with
everyone seems to be dealing with some
form of guilt guilt and especially
survivor's guilt i feel like yeah yeah
yeah that's a good way to put it
man there's a lot that happened these
are these episodes they're great though
they're really good
yeah i just want like
i know we got so many so much more hours
left to consume here
um
for this weekend but
i i think that what they're doing here
is really
there's something kind of
uh hypnotic about it um it's really
absorbing it's really really absorbing
you know transportive is the word like i
get so lost in it and a different flare
you know especially watching the other
seasons and then coming here
this has more of a
it's not slow but it's more deliberate
if that makes sense yeah it feels like
it's just allowed to take
as much time as it feels like it needs
to with each thing not too much not too
little so yeah it's like every emotional
scene gets to be what it is but they
also have a really good sense of pacing
for when to either intercut with or
introduce directly some kind of eerie
or ironic beat to keep the flavor
developing and unfolding you know
there's more of an ethereal
unsettling quality to it yeah it's got
that foreboding where you just know like
something
sinister is lurking and you just can't
even though we get glimpses in fekna and
all that stuff you still can't quite for
a lot of the regular scenes
put your finger on it it's like we know
but i think they're good at also putting
you into that place of just something's
off here and it's hard to identify it's
also a lot darker more uncomfortable
like those handheld shots that they use
just feel more
more
grounded in a reality i got a really
good contrast because there are so many
really beautifully executed and very
fluid
transitions and things that you know
require a lot of planning and a lot of
ingenuity uh but then i think they they
use those in juxtaposition so that when
they do deliberately switch to something
that's more handheld a little more
voyeuristic it really strikes you and i
think they're also good at choosing when
to do that because i feel like that's an
easy thing to go for when you want
intensity but i feel like they've used
it here also not only for intensity's
sake but like they especially in the max
scenes when she's at home it's more just
to kind of enhance that realism
yeah yeah you're really there
you know but but at the same time like
it is
it feels like a choice and it feels
striking but not in a way where it's
like super distracting it's just like oh
yeah it's another flavor they've added
to the repertoire because when i think
of the visual and the oral style of the
show i think of something symmetrical
and steady
you know i guess the easiest way to
narrow down what they're doing here is
the the other seasons rift on sci-fi
horror and this rips on supernatural
horror yeah yeah that's a good point
yeah
i like it i'm really digging it a lot i
think the the gore gags are cool that
whatever that method is
that maybe victor creel does of like
snap their bones pull back their eyes
i'll be taking these
yeah one and two i'm like are those
gonna come all the eyes gonna come back
or something like it seems very
deliberate and and he's out there
snapping people's limbs and taking their
yeah i was like jesus there's an mo for
a killer this is really you gotta have a
lot of strength
and a lot of resolve because it's hard
to do that i mean with supernatural
powers obviously much easier with the
real creole you know
who i'm excited to meet too like i like
that uh i like it's funny for as
tension-filled and as horror-oriented as
these episodes have been i also too like
that
you know vecna is still used sparingly
and is this very much sinister and
looming presence and we still haven't
even gotten to robert england
well it's it's
isn't robert e complaining guy
i think he's creel yeah yeah so like the
guy who eventually i assume soul rots
and becomes creole in the upside down
yeah this creature on the upside down
yeah
he's voicing him yeah
yeah because this vector character is a
combination of freddy krueger pennywise
and hellraiser and tyrant from resident
evil
yeah yeah
mainly the aesthetic yeah yeah yeah but
the qualities of 80s villain how are
these 80s right is 80s or 90s
hellraisers 80s yeah yeah how really
hellraiser is the it was one when i
revisited all the 80s slasher franchises
in a big way for the first time
hellraiser was the one that was just as
intense as i'd imagined from the outside
yeah and i remember being like damn for
the 80s this one did not hold back
yeah this is this is a yeah and also
like how hell razor was a villain who
could
because they used to have villains
before characters like hellraiser and i
guess the mini series for
penny and freddy krueger and stuff like
like those kinds of characters
the villains usually were scary because
they didn't talk
yes and then you had a dawn of villains
who could talk and they wouldn't shut up
who would have shut the [ __ ] up
and this this is our first season that
and and like that's what i mean like
after
there's a late 80s portion that is very
specific
and it seems to really capture that and
even does capture some of those like 80s
serial killer vibes without going full
tilt that direction
um without going full henry
no yeah yeah might be a 90s movie but
just barely yeah yeah yeah just just a
bit but it's it's really fascinating
what they're doing and and like 11 story
is one i'm
i wonder why she wants to put up the
facade though
so much so for mike so much for mike
yeah like look how happy my life is and
stuff i wonder why she's so desperate to
do that and
maybe it's just my whole thing with will
last season too of like
you know you care about hanging out with
me mike and i'm like [ __ ] mike man
cover passes yeah it has been a year why
haven't you tried and and why in this
moment are you like so
quick i mean i guess you know teenagers
and romantic problems and blah blah blah
but also like i feel like you could act
a little bit like you guys are actually
friends yeah because
like when will does confront him i'm
like yeah i mean it does seem like
you've been third wheeling him all day
and you don't really seem to care
about
being here with him
he's just kind of there
and i mean unfortunately yeah and i mean
i i hope that the will story like i i
i'm with it right now and i appreciate
it right now and i hope that it grows
into something where that actor and that
you know character can shine
well yeah it's a little repetitive for
him at this moment yes it's just deeper
voiced older
yeah
but it's at this point it's a little
repetitive so we'll see how the rest of
it unfolds like what specific
path they put him on to because it seems
like they're building up something for
him they keep having these
gazing slow shots on him of just
observing they keep faking me out too
because i always think that it's gonna
zoom in on whoever his potential love
interest could be but then no it's oh
damn it's on the camcorder guy who's
gonna make this situation even worse
but uh yeah
yeah hoping for hoping for will to to be
given something juicy here because i
like what they're doing in california in
the sense that with 11 it's the most
removed from any and everything
supernatural horror
it's all grounded in reality for 11 at
this moment well they're doing carry
with her in a lot of ways yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but even still like i'm not sitting here
going get back to the point where she
has power like i i'm actually i think
they do a good job of putting all that
uh you know all that pulp and all those
exploitable elements and things into the
rest of what's going on so that you can
have what is right now at least just a
very personal human story happening
around 11. well
it does they started off this season
with showing that i mean at least the
way it's perceived that she murdered
everyone there at the rainbow room
so
and then she gets she flashes back to
that so i mean so maybe that's like a
big part of her guilt too yeah maybe she
has an overcome and you re you still
recreate you know if you haven't
overcome it yeah
and um
when she attacks angela which by the way
ball removed 100 for it
it's fictional all right because real
life might have a different saying still
might be like okay it's kind of
deserving but yeah
we all wanted to but but you can't do it
in terms of fiction you know come on
whatever screw it like they oh well the
true tradition of the 80s i mean they
they're not completely psychotic but
they are pretty extremely they're
extreme yeah yeah they're extremely
bullied yeah they're awful um
and uh
like what does angela expect but i love
how she always singles out angela yeah
i'm like they're all bad
yeah but but take cut off the head and
the rest she's the queen she's a queen
bee yeah all these dudes ain't [ __ ]
around her because she's the nucleus but
i wonder what their what portrait
they're painting or what path they're
putting her on of you know she's
powerless right now and in all ways yeah
you know um friend wise social
circumstance wise she becomes desperate
she just wants to be normal
and she doesn't have any physical powers
and then she strikes and she's looked
upon as like this like oh my god what
did you just do this violent threat
she's haunted by her own guilt from what
she did in the past and
you know like what's it
like is there an association that having
these power having the powers prior was
a bad thing you know i saw i'm curious
to see what path they put her on to
what this all ties to thematically and
emotionally for her
of what her powers mean to her you know
because it's always seemed like a bit of
a curse
so maybe gaining them back in terms to
fight
the high school bullies you
they're going to be like we need you
never going to get back to indiana this
whole season yeah it's all going to be
in l.a it's obviously california trying
to figure out social skills oh obviously
building to her getting her powers back
and having a fight like you're a race in
the hole remember yeah you're what we
need on all the time we need to do the
thing i need you to do the thing yeah
and then go there and kill everyone at
that high school yeah lock them in the
gym they're all awful
they are pretty much all awful
that's that's terrible
yeah well no one's standing up for her
not not a single person not not anyone
no one is is decent to to jane
oh god it really sucks i i guess if
you're we're alive
for that period of time in the 80s or or
any time depicted in a stephen king
novel that features a bully let us know
is that anything approaching reality
look like if you were a freak with just
everyone the most terrible they could be
at all times
it certainly seems that way from all 80s
movies from every 80s movie ever made
yeah it was shocking i didn't expect her
to just
i really thought she was gonna break the
camera
yeah i i thought she might actually hit
her i didn't expect them to to go full
flex and i think should have been
practical effects yeah
fair yeah fair i mean i cuz two it's it
might have been hard i wonder i think
that's an area where if you are cut
there like you do kind of bleed a lot
and so
yeah i mean as much as i wish for a
practical effect it was still like oh
that is
that is some nasty looking damage and
i'm sure for everyone around that's not
gonna help 11. i love how everyone is
just like why would she do that
that's the thing wasn't there like a
billion of you who just worked
not one of you could have made the
connection to oh yeah we were all
unanimously ridiculing this person on
camera and we got the entire
establishment in on it maybe
maybe she's mad
they and like you brought up before like
generational trauma i keep wondering if
they're gonna go down some type of
cultist mentality in some areas it could
be they seem to explore that with the
bullying and then the basketball people
being like yeah they're all devil
worshipers evil dies tonight yeah
which well yeah yeah i can definitely
see some
uh i mean i like it through the scope of
the the basketball team that makes sense
yeah and then that guy like i that guy
who was jason or whatever his name is i
i he's so
someone's gonna deep fake tom cruise's
face onto his face so tom cruise to me
it's not even funny i do love i do i do
like that story i think it's this is a
really emotional and
breathes really well
and uh i think it's really earning its
run time yeah that's really engrossing
i'm like i mean you know lucas doesn't
want to stand up for anything
just gotta admit it's what we've played
just want to be popular just be like i
played it once yeah it's a fantasy game
it's like
it's it's like a board game it's not
actually satanism guys i well let me
show you
yeah
but you know i mean his position then i
i guess you know you don't want it
people really think about dungeons
that's i mean
i'm sure i've never met those people but
yeah i mean
satanic panic and yeah people singling
out heavy metal and dungeons and dragons
yeah like that's that's based on yeah
hysteria yeah i think that's where i was
thinking about the cultish fives with
the satanic panic yeah well and hey i
mean maybe they'll do something
to also nod to that as either a
misleader or maybe there is some cult of
vector out there or something
but uh it's fun wallpaper but i mean
in fact there's the dutches and dragons
character but they're i think they're
calling the big bad vector tubes yeah
they nicknamed him because that's also
the motif is yeah every like monster out
of the upside down gets a name from
demogorgon mind player yeah
so i'm just assuming there but yeah
maybe there is some kind of cult
associated
i feel like everyone's so blind with
other things in hawkins
yeah there is
this is a point where it's like which
feels very dary
yeah yeah yeah i mean dairy has that
mumbo jumbo like people seem to forget
the weird [ __ ] that happens that's not
built into here but yeah when they were
in that scene with eddie i was like
i guess maybe he wouldn't be aware of
any of the weird past several years of
feeling like yeah
yeah it seems like he would have at
least some inkling or some rumblings
about it yeah yeah so that's a that's a
piece of the continuity i guess i'll
have to check back on because i don't
know when things happen at the star
court mog gets pretty big in scope and
scale but then the biggest thing too
yeah like that yeah like nothing but
to me i go back to season one where
will's body was found
and then brought to a morgue
then they found out it wasn't really
will's body fake and then will came back
from the dead everyone's like oh well
you're alive
you're trying to forget about that whole
body swapping weirdness thing yes
yeah
what are what are the rest of the
citizens of hockey are they just uh are
they just oblivious
it's like any and all of it yeah or do
they just i guess everybody must just
sit around and go we just live in a
strange town accidents happen every day
i am not finding jonathan's story that
interesting so far it that's the only
post that's the only story that i'm like
these jokes are kind of flat and like
this and it's it's like a half-assed
cheech and chong because they don't want
to go full tilt there
but yeah it's not that funny it feels
really cliche of that character i'm
waiting for it to evolve and then i
don't know
jonathan's story just seems so like
typical too so it seems yeah very kind
of straight and wrote and i can't
foresee yet how it will grow into
anything that seems very significant his
for his story feels perfunctory because
yeah we have to include jonathan
if it's here yeah it really does because
i was sitting there during the golf
scene where there were the two of them
were you know just chucking balls and
and i was like going back and forth
thinking you know it's really cool that
they care about all their characters and
they found a way to give everybody
something to do but then by like the end
of that sequence i was like
well what that scene ended and then
later on the episode i realized we're
not cutting back to him this episode
yeah so yeah it's like it is the least
important
seeming story and it trails off the
soonest and thus it does feel like yeah
we need to have him
so we'll give him a scene each episode
yeah and that's about it and maybe we'll
use him for transpo i can almost imagine
argyle like eclipsing him as a character
because
yeah cause like i like that guy too and
the interesting characters tend to get
something to do when they enter the plot
and become a part of the series regular
cast or whatever so
yeah cause i'm not really torn between
her nancy and jonathan gonna break up
i'm like i don't
i really love them a lot in season two
as like when they're getting together i
really rooted for them a lot the context
really helps their story and then here
i'm like i just really don't kind of
kind of don't care
i don't see what's great enough beyond
your you know appearance and attitude
that's like no no man give them a chance
i want them to work this out yeah it's
sort of like i half the time i was like
are nancy and fred going to get together
or something weird like that
when when they said goodbye to each
other in season three i found that
really heartbreaking too i found that
genuinely heartbreaking um
when i rewatched it and it's weird to
it's only been a like a couple months
since i've seen that and then to come
back here
and see what's going on with them i'm
just gone yeah they're probably gonna
break them
yeah and i mean they have that one bit
where they're both talking about their
relationship and we get another beat in
this episode where they're both talking
about the relationship and they feel
more i know they're disconnected by
distance but something feels
disconnected about even they don't even
like call each other yeah like not even
like one phone call with each other yeah
and again like there's so many
circumstances i get it but i feel like
at the same time i don't really buy the
struggle coming out of them like the
dialogue is there about how you know
they're trying to convince themselves
about certain things and hey maybe we
need to break up or whatever but for
some reason it's the piece of drama that
doesn't actually ring very true or very
true vital to me
it's uh yeah
there's something about it it feels like
they're already broken up or
like uh the plot doesn't care that much
it's hard to care about them you don't
see one interaction with them
yeah or give us a reason why beyond just
what we know from before as to why we'd
want them to
work it out
all right gang well here we are
i've got uh five more episodes ago
so with this being this change you think
season four it's like 12 more hours yeah
yeah
and then when part two comes out we'll
have 18 more hours beyond this
i mean let's look at it really quick oh
let's look at the uh
uh let's do some quick math oh next
one's only an hour
okay so it's the last one that's forever
yes all right i'm looking forward to the
number 45
they could have which i bet the series
finale they might do some kind of
screening oh it'd be great to be able to
be able to experience it that way nope
we have to be here we gotta be here we
gotta be here for you guys
and we want nothing else really don't
yeah it's the this is a fun show to
share this is a fun show to share yeah i
love this show yeah i do too all right
guys see you for the next round
ricardo martinez you know why i wanted
to shout you out in stranger things
episode dos
because
there's a lack of hispanic
representation
in stranger things that's exactly what i
was gonna say yeah yeah because as two
non-hispanic people we're gonna notice
you're hispanic that's the first thing
we noticed
we thought hey we could work with it we
could work with this one i mean i got
this like stoner a guy named argyle who
i think is hispanic he could be he's
ethnically ambiguous which means
technically yes that is a californian
stoner from the 80s who's playing on
cheech and chung he's probably hispanic
okay so ricardo i think stranger things
is due
for someone like you not some
weird stoner cliche hispanic dude from
the 80s
i'm talking a good housekeeper
or you know a good gardener yeah janitor
at hawkins high janitor hawkins hi
a gangster yes you know something that's
not a cliche
something like that ricardo and i feel
like you fit any one of those identities
a low rider guy those are
non-stereotypes imagine this ricardo
martinez stranger things season five
pulls into hawkins high
low rider boom hydraulics going up and
down walks out and is like what's up
essay i want to be part of the group
ricardo you are not a cliche
i mean i'm sure maybe there's parts to
you that have like some type of uh yeah
we all have our stuff everything
ricardo does is original original now
one part honors he rejects his best
guy ever he goes i
do
or any other heritage of any existing
culture so unique
this went way off the rails
look thanks for being here recording
yeah
trying to come up with something new
thank you for being here and uh you know
we're just messing around gracias
gracias amigo
from us
people
all right
god bless
[Music]
you